so if I were to teach this course to a
group that would be much more diverse
than what we have at MIT because I think
so when we taught this course in this
past spring most students came with a
very open mind trying to understand the
way indeed race and language created
Iraqis that are not good for the country
not good for the world and how to create
more inclusive societies but if I were
to teach this course with a more diverse
a logical set of students what I think
ash I would do is to include more text
from the more conservative perspective
in fact some of the students often they
would bring in clips from the breadboard
or from Rush Limbaugh you know forces
that are very conservative and some of
them even on the old right extreme and
we use that as for teaching movements
but but if if I were to teach this class
maybe to a more diverse group what I
would do is to not take our views so
extreme but take some scholarly work
that could advocate say for building
walls and then to examine them trying to
examine them together in a respectful
way so that way even students on the
right and and on the Left could have a
respectful dialogue and try to look at
the data that might support a particular
view versus the other and that would be
a challenge but I think eventually it
would be a good challenge because one
one common motif throughout the semester
was how do we take what we learn here in
this course and make it available to the
wider public including those who might
want to build walls and not bridges how
do we translate all these very important
knowledge all these important findings
about migration about equality how do we
translate that in a way that it can be
discussed in a wider sphere and and it's
remain a challenge to the very end of
the class there was no clear answer on
how to do that per se but I would hope
that if we were to teach to broader
audience would come up with the right
way to do it
you